bebeaucoup. À suivre. Avec nous,
lala Docteur Cécile Tremblay. E-
cece qu'on va connaître toutes s
lelettres grecques comme ça une
apaprès les autres? Pour ceux qi
sese posent la question, on
rarappelle que c'est des lettres
grgrecques. L'OMS qui désignent
leles nouveau variant avec une
nonouvelle lettre grecque.
EsEst-ce que ce variant... je vs
vovous poser des questions très
prprécises dans une seconde, mas
dede façon générale, est-ce quea
vovous inquiète?
- - Ce n'est pas une surprise et
çaça m'inquiète. Oui, c'est dans
lala nature de la bête de se
trtransformer. Plus il va y avor
dede la transmission
cocommunautaire, et ce n'importe
ouoù dans le monde, en Europe ou
auaux États-Unis, il va y avoir
l'l'émergence de nouveaux varia.
EtEt quand variant émerge,
hahabituellement celui qui gagne
lala partie est celui qui est le
plplus capable de se transmettr,
dodonc qui est le plus contagie.
CÇa semble être le cas avec
cecelui-là. Mais on n'en sait ts
pepeu sur ses caractéristiques t
sasa virulence et sa façon
d'd'échapper au système
imimmunitaire ou non.
- - Je vais vous poser une
ququestion à la fois. Est-ce qun
s's'est si les plus contagieux?
EsEst-ce qu'on laissait lundi à
1717h04?
- - On est pas certain. Mais on
pepense que des indices nous dit
ququ'il est contagieux.
EnEn peu de temps en Afrique du
SuSud, il a remplacé le Delta de
totous les cas qui sont arrivés.
MaMais ce n'est pas encore étabi
paparce que ça nous prend des
dédénominateurs pour l'établir.
- - Il a remplacé très rapidemet
lele Delta. C'est lui qui a prie
lala place. Il est à peu près
partout maintenant.
- - Il a remplacé le Delta en
AfAfrique du Sud. Mais quand on
didit que ce qu'il y a des cas
papartout, ce sont en majorité s
cacas importés. C'est des gens i
avavaient voyagé en Afrique et i
sosont arrivés dans leur pays. l
n'n'y a pas de transmission
cocommunautaire dans ces pays,
mamais tout ça peut changer d'ue
heheure à l'autre.
- Deuxième question, est-il plus
vivirulent, donc plus dangereux?
- - Présentement, on n'a pas
d'd'indication que c'est le cas.
OnOn ne le sait pas. Ça va prene
unun plus grand nombre
d'd'infections pour calculer les
prproportions des gens qui se
rerendent à l'hôpital suite àà e
ininfection. Les cas qui sont
susurvenus, où on les a le plus
ététudié, c'est en Afrique du S.
IlIl n'y avait pas d'évidence
ququ'il était plus virulent, mas
c'c'est trop tôt pour le dire.
- - Plus résistants au vaccin?
S'S'il était plus virulent, on
vovoudrait que les vaccins soiet
efefficaces.
- - C'est la grande inquiétude.e
papattern de mutation qui est
obobservée chez ce mutant, il a
unune trentaine de mutations das
lala protéine. Et parmi ces
mumutations, il y a des mutatios
ququ'on retrouvait dans le varit
BBêta qui avait une baisse de
sesensibilité au vaccin. On ne
sasait pas s'il y en a plus que
dadans les autres variant. Ça pt
coconférer soit une plus grande
rérésistance au vaccin ou peut-
êêtre aucune résistance au
vavaccin. On ne le fait pas. C't
popour ça que les études
prprésentement en laboratoire, a
prprend quand même quelques tems
paparce qu'il faut fabriquer des
mimini virus pour pouvoir faire
leles tests de laboratoire. D'ii
dedeux semaines, on devrait le
sasavoir.
- - D'ici deux semaines, on va
êêtre fixé.
- - On devrait être fixé sur la
cacapacité des anticorps qu'on a
prprélevés chez les gens qui ont
fafait la maladie et les anticos
ququ'on va prélever chez les ges
dodoublement vaccinés. Ont testé
lele virus contre ces anticorpst
onon voit si les anticorps
réréussissent à le neutraliser.
- - D'où votre inquiétude, mais
papas de panique pour l'instant.
OnOn surveille la virulence et i
leles vaccins sont encore
efefficaces. Est-ce que ça nous
amamène pas, en terminant une
dedernière question. Pour tous s
papays de la planète, si on
reregarde beaucoup de pays du Sd
nonon vacciné, je ne fais pas
paparticulièrement référence à a
l'l'Afrique du Sud non vaccinée
s's'il y a encore de grandes
popoches de non vacciné, est-ce
ququ'on n'est pas encore pris àe
quque la rououe tourne
cocontinuellement?
- - Une pandémie, c'est global.
QuQuand on laisse le virus de
rérépliquer, que ce soit en
EuEurope, il faut faire un effot
susupplémentaire pour vacciner
l'l'ensemble des citoyens de la
plplanète. Et ça passe par deux
chchoses. D'une part, rendre les
vavaccins accessibles, mais c'et
momoins ça le problème
prprésentement parce qu'on a des
vavaccin. Les États-Unis en ont
tetellement qu'il les donne. La
didifficulté la plus importante,
c'c'est les capacités de vaccin,
alaller donner ses doses au
papatient. Les infrastructures e
sasanté faible dans plusieurs
papays, c'est l'incapacité de
memener une campagne de
vavaccination massive qui est un
dedes plus grands défis
prprésentement. Mais il faut fae
totous nos efforts pour les
apappuyer.
- - Temps que tout le monde ne
sesera pas guéri, on ne sera pas
guguéri totalement. Noël, votre
inintuition vous dit quoi sur ls
rarassemblements? On ne peut pas
dedemander aux gens de reculer
ququand même.
- - Mon intuition me dit la même
chchose qu'elle me disait avante
nonouveau variant. Soyons prudes
etet vigilants. Les cas montent,
onon a libéralisé certaines
memesures. On s'attendait à voir
leles commenter et c'est ce quie
papasse. Maintenant, on n'a pas
enencore vu d'augmentation
d'd'hospitalisation, mais il fat
sese donner quelque semaines avt
dede voir sa. Je me dis qu'il va
fafalloir rester prudent pendant
lele temps des fêtes. Ce nene sa
papas le temps de faire de grans
rarassemblements de familles. Et
sisi le nouveau variant nous
enenvahit, il va falloir être
enencore plus prudent.
- - Rassemblements, mais pas trs
grgros. Le côté lumineux de la
prproposition, des rassemblemens
mamais pas à 45.
- - Je vous rappelle que le
mamasque, le lavage des mains et
lala distanciation, ça marche
cocontre tous les virus, que ce
sosoit le Delta, l'influence oua
gagastro-entérite. Ce sont de
bobonne protection qui nous
prprotège contre toutes sortes e
chchoses.
- - On va se reparle